I wish you all the best but it's not
happening no I can't do this anymore
you're crazy crazy you're crazy you're a
little crazy person
and we're back shit's and gigs 29 miles
repping up plus ultra talks today plus
anime geeks is it on the reverse is it
flips I don't know if he's gonna flip on
the camera but I've got a sticker on my
laptop and if you know what plus otras
front more if you don't know what my
first and foremost and you watch anime
embarrassment yeah but second of all if
you do if you don't watch it and you
want to know what's wrong and you watch
anime oh you wanna watch more enemy
it's from MHA which is my hero do you
say academic minor academia academia
academia academia and that same same
anyway yesterday and you're not today
what season four finale it's it's heavy
it's been something you've wanted to see
for a while and I've been behind so yeah
oh yeah man yeah man boy random you know
I had a man damn mmm who do things got
the biggest piece oh my god I've never
actually thought about that you provide
until it just run any pops in my head
the other day who do things with a
big-ass dick outfit out of the months
okay you answer that question fun
because if I say yeah cuz it all that
matter love our boys watch this so if I
say one of them they're gonna be like
they're gonna be just that's fine I
don't mind gassing on one of the months
probably Toby in it I don't know I wreck
is probably Toby that's too humble he's
too humble he knows he's got something
that no one else has he's always had
that humility he's always had it so he
must have the biggest dick that's funny
I don't know I I don't know I don't know
I'm just gonna [ __ ] arriva boy I
don't know unless that's hella that's
hella that's too much I don't know about
anything is there phone I don't want to
say me because I feel like that's
bolston do you ever think and that's
definitely me I'd every because me but
you ever do you ever
like people's just people like how do I
say it
so I've never seen none of you man
sticks yeah especially hard but that's
the only where it matters it is that's
where that's what we get down to it yeah
I've never seen uh Nima's dick but like
obviously we would do you ever feel do
you ever feel like it might not be
anyone from our circle but you ever feel
like you've been speaking to someone and
they're gassing things so obviously
there's certain traits yeah so how do
perfectly Gong but remember what
remember the film four year old virgin
yes when they clock bet he's a virgin
when they're playing poker whatever and
they're talking about T's and nipples in
song by that and he starts describing T
and it just ain't making sense what he
saves ain't making sense do you ever
feel like obviously when you're talking
about like like big dick problems like
this thing yeah and when you're hitting
hitting the wall yeah and all this stuff
and like do you ever feel like you ever
feel like you've ever spoken to someone
and you've been having that kind of
conversation and you be thinking this
guy doesn't know what is no more
apparently I can't think of a time I
reckon is definitely being some guys
I've been like yeah yeah yeah that way
that was stressful that will hit him Gus
problems it reminds me of white chicks
in the hotel when they're and went away
and brothers I've see if they're they're
females and they're showing their other
white friends how to suck dick do you
remember yeah and you're like never put
in your mouth yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's why yes exactly
actually speaking of I remember there's
a time there was a time one of my boys
um he said this to me and I just had a
hint of fabrication man said um What did
he say man said uh I've never [ __ ] a
girl yeah and it didn't hurt I'm not
speaking that's a lie that's a lie
that's a lie
you've probably uh it could be true but
you probably only [ __ ] two people now
this is the thing I know I never [ __ ]
this guy's foot mmm I know this guy's
[ __ ]
I just I just know yeah cuz obviously
I've this huh it sounds disgusting I've
heard people I haven't heard people yeah
say you haven't happy here of course is
there's a ting sir how do explain
certain girls just can't handle it yeah
and certain girls just can't can ya they
just can't
I'm it they can just firm it yeah and
that's just how they're built yeah and
the amount of girls that I know for a
fact that he's [ __ ]
plus the ones that I don't even know
about I know for a fact it's definitely
not true yeah that every single girl
that this guy's [ __ ] he's her I just
know it's not is you fabricating and
just just looking at him as a factor and
how he's put together you're an idol
your lightest wine beer and I don't know
why you need to boost your ego yeah no
one's trying to doubt you ever yeah we
weren't even talking about he'll and
talking about you were talking about her
and anyone from we're just having a
little a little guy chat he just came
out of it
so unprovoked anyone who's giving me
unprovoked sex max you're a liar but oh
there's all one say hmm this is what I
wanted to say two points yeah we might
get Freebo from we might not know how or
why should I get for you first first one
some people legit need to get cheated on
not need to deserve to deserve to you
you deserve to some people deserve to
get their heart broken I deserve to get
cheated on so I was talking to someone
the other day yeah they they add hot
listen to this so wherever God is if
they listen to this one and I it doesn't
matter I grilled them anyway yeah it's a
female and they were talking this is how
they hit me up they hit me up and they
were like James I need some guy advice
so talking about like another guy and I
was like cool I'll bill you tell me you
tell me what the issue isn't she's like
yeah I just want to talk to you because
I know you're hitting me you'll give it
to me straight
like whether like whether or not like
I'm doing the right thing saying the
right thing whatever
so I Bella now and I'm like wall gone
was you guy issue ma'am she's out well
talking to this guy I've known him about
a week I think she said they slept
together whatever
like sooner than she would usually see
with someone yeah but they've been
talking for like a week max so they
don't even know each other yeah I think
they [ __ ] they must have thought the
first time they see what yeah yeah this
is pre Corolla nah this is now current
yes you've been breaking rules from so
you've been breaking quarantine is a
locally spreading it like oh that's what
my never met man but you willing to
break quarantine oh that's a sexy talk
it [ __ ] with that sexy talk enough
[ __ ] with it I had a low-key lip bye
cuz I said when she said I'll be talking
about we I said have you met this guy
and she was like yeah yeah binoy and I
was up but I did for dick you willing to
break the rules
alright but yes she told me she's our
talking for about a week and then he
kind of like the the conversation kind
of dried up kind of thing yeah and I was
all right and she's like I'm and then he
hit me up the other day
matt said oh can you do me a massive
favour she's like what man said can I
borrow 400 quid what let's say can I
borrow four bills
what and she said I didn't even go 400
to give you a man said I escaped that
can about 120 firm and I said to her I
don't understand so what's the guy issue
you're having yeah I was the predicament
that you have in here and she was like
well do I give him the benefit in the
Dow or do I just lock it off now
I thought that issue it's his issue
it's just her issue I was like I don't
understand the issue you're having you
it she was like whoa do I carry on
seeing him or not and I was like no no
that's not an issue what we're talking
about no an issue
I'm not [ __ ] someone imagine imagine
I [ __ ] ago and then next week she asked
me for four bills firm won't even know
you
I literally don't know you yes we've had
sex I don't know you why am i giving you
four hundred pounds I wouldn't even want
to ask you for four hundred pounds it
needs to be a dire situation from asking
you for four bills 100 percent 100
I don't even ask my mom for four bills
and you ask a stranger stranger stranger
you were stranger I don't know ten
things about you fam I don't know your
surname
I probably I probably don't know your
surname I don't know where your boys
call you I don't know anything for bit
when you ask me for four bills
we're not ain't got food boys you ask me
for 120 so it's not even like you're
investing this money it's a very nice
job I'm definitely getting back yeah
I've never a fam not kids you dropped it
to 120 I'm getting it but I'm not seeing
these footballs again because if you
needed four bills you will stick to four
bills um cuz if you need four bills you
need four bills if um if you need four
bills you need it for something specific
any back the next day or the day after
hundred percent you're you're saying to
your chest can you do me a big favor any
before because you don't know me who did
you ask first you've asked a couple
manfor firm couple man first big man
we're done here I'm blocking in shine
it's an into the manage and then I'm
blocking your number immediately
hey you much like this these crazy hoe
is asking me for four bills locked up
bro you're cracking and you've gotta
cheap to ask me for 120 you're a crooked
that record or you're in debt that's
dead you're in gambling that's you're in
there you're in you owe someone some fun
you've been furloughed and you had you
can't afford your bill's sponsor way
you're saving and your Daris furloughed
you and not you know your desk you're
desperate no you're asking me someone
you don't know for money for my nose
roll Harrison she said do I give him the
benefit of doubt oh you need you deserve
to get cheated on there but you're the
kind of person who deserves to get
cheated on oh you deserve heartbreak
because I don't understand what the
issue is here and they should message me
day after now I did decide to lock it in
the end you deserve mainly your life I'm
sorry you just said you my age no no no
she's a year older than us no no
she'sshe's not lived
she's not experienced anything but she
says to me she said to me in the past
like why do i why am i attracted to
[ __ ] it's because you you can't see
a red flag when it's a part of your face
yeah you're an enabler
that's what you are you're an enabler
your job you've got underlying issues
but the Garonne is right for you firm
because you've got underlying issues you
need to think you need to have a hard
thing to look at yourself I think this
is your time
this is the biggest red flag a guy I
don't know has come to you asking for
money
vasin and you're willing to carry on
seeing this guy do willing to enter your
the fact that you've gone out of your
way to ask someone else is this the
right thing to do you already know it's
the wrong thing to do if you're asking
someone else for advice about situation
already know you know it's it's wrong
you know buddy what planet was I ever
gonna say carry on seeing him on what
planet was I ever gonna say that you put
into perspective when you said you ain't
even asked me for four bills bro you'd
have to be in a dire situation to asking
for for Bill and I'm telling you fam
four bills until Friday
are you giving me a day like a family
exactly when you get it back and if I
said to you from I'm really sorry to ask
can you do me a massive a I need four
bills if you hit me back up and was like
oh I'm sorry I don't even have four
bills yeah if I immediately said okay
coke 120 you say General Scott now
what's good what's going on what what do
you need it for why have it gone from
four girls to once when he was coming on
tell me what problem is is 120 solving
cuz you said four so what's the actually
for what do you need the drug was
actually for most drugs dangerous that's
dangerous found so far are you deserve
to you ignore red flags and you deserve
to catch a dumb [ __ ] that's funny that's
what you want from your life that's
funny
no it made me think as a follow Bob poem
yeah has there ever been a time in your
life where you've definitely ignored red
flags subconsciously or consciously oh
yes for sure I just didn't got bitten in
in the end I wouldn't necessarily got
bitten but yes I've ignored red flags
now what
so does a check I was [ __ ] with some
time last year like the end of summer
maybe last year and she's why I was
gonna say she was why she is white but
she's she's a white girl that loves
everything black black men black music I
mean and there was a times there's a
chick that I went to Union with her name
is it doesn't matter anyways but she was
she wasn't a TV show I come up with TV
shows quit actually and this girl was
[ __ ] with at the time used to watch
that TV show and she was like ah
that because she she wants mixed-race
kids like she's her heart selling it so
she yeah yeah
and this is gold she used to watch on a
TV show who was obviously black she was
like oh I wish I was her I'm thinking
what Jesus Christ she kept on saying I
wish I was black I wish I was black I'm
Jesus Christ what to start as if he was
back you and be getting any back pin so
I'm just saying it's just like that's
such that's such an that's such a bold
statement to say I wish I was brush I
was black like yes what's going on in
your life what do you know I mean you're
white firm you're white you're winning
you've won the game you're out here
you're just out here wide just with all
the rights to you and you want to be
black I'm not saying there's an
obviously nothing wrong but I love being
black but like the fact that you what
are you saying that you're not
experiencing like what you see no that
wasn't so greener over here like what is
greener that you're thinking I'm missing
out hey I blew my mind
obviously there was no negative effects
on me per se because I still [ __ ] out
yeah [ __ ] her before she said that
comment and I was [ __ ] her after that
comment yeah it's like where she said I
suppose thinking what that I didn't I
didn't react the way I'm reacting now
yeah sweet walls I've got their walls
pre and post crazy talk hilarious but it
made me think that a red flag that's a
red flag cuz she was she's willing to do
anything to have a mixed-race kids oh I
see see that's not why I want to hear
cuz she she's adamant who does tell me
that's not want anything that's like you
don't even know what another race can
bring to your life like you can meet
them last have you ever seen love is
blind or Netflix now but you have you
heard of it you've heard I've heard of
it you know I'm not watching Sheila you
know the pre you know
the show I don't know okay so basically
in like the first couple weeks or the
first few episodes of the show what is
in a bit
the first few episodes of the show they
are it's basically like a Big Brother
house I look money to come back to be
here it's kind of like a big growth
house but the men are separated for the
women and they can only communicate
through pods but they're in in the pod
so it's one massive house the men live
on less say the left side them live on
the right side yeah but there's pods
interlink in the house so the men can
only talk to the women through these
spots but the pods are blocked off with
a water you can't see through them you
can only hear their voice so you get to
know someone just by the voice so a lot
a lot a few relationships and marriages
per se have been reformed through this
show so that's what seemed like and one
of the relationship is an interracial
relationship so the guy is why the
woman's black and they're the black the
most like popular people on that show or
from that show because of it's an
interrelationship and the woman is black
more interrelation a more interracial
relationships the guys usually black and
the room is white but because the
woman's black and the guy is why a lot
of women a lot of black women especially
irate in it because oh yes you go you
bla bla bla bla bla bla go with if you
needed that you're happy
you deserve her but if we flipped it and
the guy was black and like we see a lot
of interrelationship and interracial
relationships today and if a black guy
is I'm I faltered his judgment as well
if a black guy is with a thick white
girl oh you autumn I see think he's only
there to bust nuts
that's your automatic fall in it you
don't give a [ __ ] she could be the best
person in the world to you all I think
about is this guy's not jealous he's not
in do you think about I'm not so sure
that's all about fact or not if she's
rough thick and white your Seng and the
guys lost six four stacks here's one
this game they're not talking from
there's nothing to talk about what black
girls will be hating on Oh from your
angles or
yes but let me say it bocalee you wanna
go there you waitress if it's if roles
are reversed if it's vice-versa
the guy is white and a woman's black
they rate it so highly but it's still an
interracial interrupt
there's or what is it weave it sounds
like I'm hey no black guys I'm actually
not yeah even though I'll come back to I
used to have such a stigma against bad
girls because they used to bully me
anyway maybe not I'll come back to it
I'll come back yeah um why the black
girls want every type of guy do you
wanna be only with black girls so
exactly what you just said if there's a
white guy especially if he's
good-looking it's a good-looking white
girl fighting with a black girl yeah
it's rating rating its ratings girl or
family and if a what if a black guys day
and a white girl black girls are vexing
black guys aren't X black girls are
furious stealing our women see nah man
all these stuff like this is why [ __ ]
black girls have to get we've to look
white in all this all this makeup she
and all they say all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like why do you not want everyone to be
with everyone why do you only want the
guys of any race to only be were black
me I don't understand like I've never
seen a divide like there is between
black women and any idea of the race of
women they don't really give a [ __ ]
about Asian women but black women and
white women there's such a divide I feel
like black women are the cause of their
own problems yes that's a shower
that's a shower yeah I know so many
black women must this is about my mom's
back sure I mean but I've got nothing at
I date black women that it had nothing
against them but it's just the fact that
it's so stigmatized that if a white guy
is with a black woman they get praised
the women get praised but if the roles
were reversed right like you said oh
you're stealing our men it's like why
you so against it
big man if she makes him happy who are
you who literally gives up why are you
to judge them when I go back to the
singer bum and they used to bully me the
only stress I've ever received about
being mixed race is from black women
black girls and when I was in school I
got
every name under the Sun by black girls
from just like how he was in like in uni
every black girl become Eli I don't even
know the light use the nicest of it yeah
no black going uni every call boot James
never it was always like if we're
walking down the street it'll be hi
Aaron - hi Jacob
ye that's exactly whatever your life is
you know history of them didn't that's
all I didn't bother me because I was
used to it yeah but only black women
ever you get and ever give me that yeah
and when I was in school there was a
group of black girls in my year that
would bully me religiously it didn't it
didn't [ __ ] bother me because they
were hideous anyway I used to gun them
hideous um so but boy in fact on a daily
it would be like they used to call me
half-breed [ __ ] they would say my dad is
a sellout they would say like obviously
like being mixed-race I'll say you're
mixed up you're confused what the [ __ ]
man begging trying to be black when
you're not fam also some black girls all
sorts and obviously I had to chuck it
back yeah so I apologize to anyone if I
offended you like peripherally when I
was gunning for these men but I had to
chuck it back up it was obviously yeah
it was peak the elbows wide why is it I
should well I had to but where they used
to going for me yeah I can from the back
and imagine I was there for you news oh
and they say um why don't your dad's a
sellout in it I realize white ghost man
from yeah ways coming from most hatred
in you why that's funny
but I'm taking it back to the girl that
was seeing sorry so if for example she
was in that experiment and she got to
know someone that was white well rah
what's to stop her from being happy with
the white guy do you know I mean
Christian was a mix kids we're desperate
to have mixed-race kids she wants to be
she said she wants to be black she wants
to have mixed-race kids I have to be
with a black gun like why do you have to
be with a black guy why'd she tell you
this there's a red flag then and there
all right but so your white friends this
chat I wanted
Sweetwater of course yeah but I'm
thinking for her perspective why is she
telling you yes she should not think he
must income crazy did not cross they had
one time I don't think I think I think
sometimes when they get so involved in
that kind of conversation especially
with the black person they probably
think we rate it yeah well we I'm
thinking obviously I thought was a red
flag I knew it was a red flag and I knew
nothing was gonna amount from what we
had going on anywhere I just knew it was
fun at the time but it's like why would
you comfortably say that did you not I
mean I always mean think almond if
there's ever been girls that I've ever
been with my white girls that have ever
fought about their race in our
relationships context mm-hmm I've really
been with many white girls but
relationship wise well relationship wise
go sex-wise loads I'm thinking wait you
go with this I've [ __ ] many a white
thing mainly a white thing but it does a
relation actually haven't been in like
long form relationships with that many
white girls a few yeah but I've never
thought like do they ever put their
their race in standing and thinking like
oh I wonder if he is disappointed on why
or something like that I don't know if
they've all like that I guess the fact
that my mom's white probably they don't
care yeah I feel like because they know
your mix raced they would how can i word
it not necessarily give you the benefit
of the doubt but they would if they ever
like had that kind of stigma that the
black girls have they would understand
that because your mom's white and I'm
why you're gonna be okay with it yeah
it's never gonna be in their mind as
much as yeah if it's black and they're
coming to see my black mom yeah the mom
probably thinks I wish I was black [ __ ]
like that oh [ __ ] yeah your mom
definitely would want them to be black
in it
oh my almost death most death most death
well my mom knows me she my mum now know
sometimes your your appetite yes
she knows look the hell my mom held that
Elwell cuz she's been said I said it
prior before in this podcast mom was
always wanting me to marry Nigeria and
always one thing tomorrow Muslim because
my family is mostly them all of that I
don't thinking why does it concern you
who I marry who I'm Way of like at the
end of the day if I am happy why are you
bothered
Shirley might happen as supercede
Trump's anything but Trump's anything
this is who literally gives a [ __ ]
because if once I'm married I'm out of
your life I feel like they forget that
yeah obviously I don't leave my parents
now yeah yeah I am even more gonna be
out of their lives if I married and have
kids because you're not gonna be my top
priority yeah yeah sure you might happen
I should supersede any kind of notion
you've got on race religion about
whoever I'm gonna be I can't even
imagine ever maybe it's just the the
world I've grown up in but like I can't
imagine ever caring about who my child
is with I couldn't I guess there as long
as my child is happy obviously yeah if
they weave a Duke it if they're a dick
I'm gonna care about your race or a
[ __ ] you're gone yeah yeah I care
about your yeah yeah yeah but it's I
that's wild that is wild and people want
to change their race imagine like I
can't imagine stuff if there was an
actual way for people to change race I
guarantee a lot of people do it a lot of
people would do it if there was a way
would you think that what populace
wouldn't say most to what the most I
feel like they'll be so many white girls
though not so many if there'll be a lot
of white girls that'll change to either
mixed-race or black black take mistake
numero uno but I feel like there'll be a
lot of black people that want to change
to white purely because they don't want
to experience white privilege I know
what you're saying you know I'm coming
they won't necessarily wanna be white
they just want that privilege because I
love being black
I'm sure all black people let up you
know I love so it's like they would only
want to experience it they wouldn't want
to stay like that for yeah you know I
want to be white for a week yeah let me
double with a rich white folk for these
things
I reckon if I can live my life there be
bare I reckon there be bare white guys
that we want to try being black facts
because this is stupid
this is stupid in order to shoot me down
but this is stupid don't think it's
weird that there's all there's an
attachment between being black yeah and
being cool hundred so then black guys
don't think they're cool yeah but like
guys cuz yeah it's like if white guys
basically think a black guy can do
anything and remain cool 100 oh I'm
saying anything you do smooth and sample
like I've always thought like I've
always wondered like why is the only
black guys that watch anime like why all
the people that I've ever met that watch
and made the rule black yeah and I'm
probably thought like it's probably
because they're less likely oh they're
more comp maybe just as many white
people probably watch anime yeah but
they're less likely to admit because the
perception if they watch anime is there
they're just nerds yeah [ __ ] losers
they're just grown men what should anime
they're a loser watching when you're a
black that into a Thursday like I'll do
what the [ __ ] I want yeah yeah that's
cool oh where why what do I want like is
whoever liked it I have no worries about
being a boss about the way people think
about me yeah and I don't think that's
because I'm black but I do think a lot
of people think that like black people
can do what they want and how they want
and still having that like you know when
people say like I can't pull that off
but they'll always say a black guy can
pull that off like I was listen to a
podcast the other day and they were
talking about like it was it was an item
of clover come over it's a ha or like a
certain shirt or something like that and
they were say like I can't pull that off
like only they'll say like only like gay
so I think was a hat I can't member what
kind of high was it was like a hat and
they were like bro I can't pull that off
like a gay singer can pull that off and
then the other guy was like and I black
back and pulled it off and guy was like
brother black guy can pull that off a
black guy can pull anything off and it's
actually true and it even works with
like the blacker you are the more you
can pull off yeah like when you wear
your like loud shirts yeah like your
floral goatee wherever silk shirt I can
not pull up there's too much white meets
ball that I can't pull it off and that's
a fact
people think I'm a homosexual it's true
if you're light-skinned you're wearing a
a loud shirt you're gay
yeah rags if you're black you you're
cool as [ __ ] you know your skin looks
amazing you're glowing
I think there's a lot of white guys that
would want to try being black yeah cuz I
think is cool they're just cool now like
if you yeah you're a black guy you're
cool you can dye your hair still just
cool you can have a beer still that's
cool you can shave your beard still
looks cool like you can wear the [ __ ]
you want still that's cool
so I think there's a lot of guys that
would try that a lot of white guys want
to be black to see their dick size see
if they got a bigger dick see they got a
bigger dick
let me see these rumors are true you
know what I would want to try as well
being like a Chinese guy oh not
necessarily Chinese but like that kind
of that kind of Asian yeah like I random
I've got a Domino's delivery the other
day yeah and the guy was like he was
Asian
yeah and he just had like like a sleeve
you know I've got [ __ ] sleeve but he
had a sleeve he had like he was a little
bit jacked and he just like had like
that you know that golden Asian skin
tone that kind of like Vietnamese kind
of look another ten miles like and he
just like came in was that what
something gave me a singing any would
talk yeah man I just thought certain
Asian guys are cool as [ __ ] yeah I don't
know why they I don't know what they can
pull certain things off we're all aging
there's a lot of things off Asian guys
can pull a lot of me just automatically
think these men can fight as soon as you
said he had a sleeve Taekwondo bro the
judo that means I think there's
something to it they can swing they can
fight they can do they can dance they
can sing they can dance they can pop and
lock the dais and I don't get it there's
certain in their joints bro aging people
can do [ __ ] they can do [ __ ] that other
people just can't can't do yeah and it's
just like there's certain things about
being Asian that's just cold as [ __ ]
yeah so like if you're let's just say
like someone comes up and they're like
would you do yeah annular I want my
breakdancer immediate gonna laugh in
your face yeah who does breakdancing
yeah if you're Asian you tell me you're
breakdance for ShowMe sauce show me
something now because I know you're
heavy show me your Instagram sorry I'm
fast I'm not Barris for you I'm gas
because I know you're gonna be see I
know you're gonna blow mine bro alight
at the same time if I see an Asian guy
on a basketball court handles he's sick
he's serving me something he's he's got
sign up his sleeve yeah I don't know
this I'll be an agent if you
cool and on the female side agent
females they're coming up up up you know
about signing your horoscope you man a
buff Humana or buff I told you remember
what I say the other day when like when
you're if you're in 100% dog mode guys
will understand that if you're in
hundreds a dog mode if you're a black
guy in your $100 mode yeah if you see a
group of black girls and one Chinese got
in there you know she [ __ ] black guys
she won a hundred percent she's she's
always blah she's ready she's always
buff cream of the crop always buff it's
weird it's so weird that a stigma exists
bro it doesn't make any sense
no sir they appear out of nowhere yeah I
can no one's ever had that comment that
thing I just said yeah I've never had
that conversation with anyone ever but
as soon as I say people like ya make
sense racks it makes sense hundred
percent yeah and they can automatically
dance they can move their hips if they
could dance on top of that there's a
part of the little the dancer society in
in Union it and they all love one
hundred percent yeah yeah boy yeah Asian
girls are coming up in the world boy oh
yeah that's buff buff buff but yeah man
what the [ __ ] was a oh that's like from
the red flag talk in it mmm I don't
think there's definitely times I've
ignored red flags Oh every time this
time Flags this beat me the one
girlfriend I had he was throwing red
flags left finds enough D mmm she was
Fuhrman red flags from early she was she
was the psych eval I remember so she had
for context pike people's I had a
girlfriend I was seen when I was a
younger man we dated for like three
years and you work with her before I met
you yeah yeah yeah before me and she was
a lovely person
lovely lovely lovely goreng woman but
she was crazy I don't know she's still
crazy probably someone crazy she was
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy and
this slight tangent I'll get back to the
crazy I always knew she had a thing for
white guys don't know why I knew that I
just knew it
oh so you never
I just I it was more than an inclination
I just I knew be like how do you explain
it like I didn't have the evidence to
support it like just knew me okay
like a boyfriend performing was black
and she got with me but I just knew
she'd like white guys okay and then
there was one she used to be a fashion
designer there was one guy she always
used to asked a model for he's a white
guy and I'm speaking she fasted though
[ __ ] out this I just know it I'm not
powering iconic guy but I just know it
and I swear I saw that she was dating
him after we broke up and I remember
thinking thank God
like wasn't me weight off my chest yeah
nothing come on now is white as well
okay um but anyway
she was crazy she was throwing up red
flags from early early early early early
I remember there was a time there was
time when we're at uni I went to stay at
hers I think I've told this story a
million times and I got a Valentine's
Day text it was Valentine's Day when I
was at her house mm-hmm
I got a text from one of um not even
three of mutual person at how unique who
happened to be female and she's in a
group text round to everyone in our
contact book was like treat your partner
right today all this stuff like have a
great day there's a normal Valentine's
Day group text and since everyone she
knew and my girlfriend saw it I was like
who the [ __ ] is this yeah I don't know
it's just some random girl for me and
she said why'd she have your number and
I was like she had my number because she
lived in the block opposite me I think
something like she's listening she could
hear the music I was playing out in my
room yeah and she said how do you have
this back in the day where people have
CDs and [ __ ] or she said like when the
people using memory sticks yeah she said
do you mind if I bring my memory stick
to yours you coulda said me some music
oh [ __ ] oh Tom text me when you're
outside back then had my number from
there never spoke to her again so why do
you have a number explained that's where
she was like that's the biggest amount
[ __ ] I've ever heard and the joke
thing is you'll know if you saw this
girl she was hideous she was hideous
she's about six foot seven she was like
20 years old thumb nose pierced about 20
years old about in 96 she was gross um I
don't know why she look like she's suck
dick I do you know I'm saying you know
you know
what you mean because when you've got
nothing else to give you have to be good
at something and that something is given
hurt that's why I said I think I've said
on here before fat girls give the best
like I think I've said on a before well
I've never [ __ ] a fat girl like fit
girls like thick fit girls because nine
times out of ten not that's not not
necessarily that's all they've got to
give but they have to be good at that
yeah yeah because there's only so many
positions you can do yeah I didn't have
to be good at it it's not thing is this
not even it's not even like a bat isn't
it's not even a negative point yeah it's
the fact that girls who are super super
good-looking thing taking to skirt on
that and they're wrong and they're wrong
and they're never gonna achieve anything
in life if you think you're paying and
you can just go on through [ __ ] you Peng
girls a lot I have seen so many girls
that I think rah
I can't wait B to suck my dick and you
are so average and I'm thinking is this
all you bring to the table
obviously the sex could be bomb but like
I'm more I would obviously bust my nut
umbrella Rob because I'm gas that you're
boffin I'm [ __ ] you yeah I love him
you all know my love head so for the
fact that a head is dead makes you think
you're not is thanking you from here to
here Oh hundreds understand think you
for me and find rude you're cruising
through life thinking you can get away
with murder but you're not even that
good in the sack right as a package
you're not even that good rags and it's
more than a song for us but we can't
last long here but yeah no more than
this your novelty I'm never gonna forget
today and I'm gone tomorrow face value
is isn't nil to me now um but yeah
anyway this girl's gross yeah and then
they're my [ __ ] girlfriend at the
time I went in the shower she unlocked
my phone when I was in the shower
and she was one of them goes that's like
give me your passcode if you ain't
giving me your password you got science
to hide all this [ __ ] I was I bother for
this let's have it
she went from my phone got the girl's
number she lived in a different City so
when I was on my way back to our city
she decided to ring that who rings
people
she decided to ring the go ask her the
truth now then when this girl told her
the truth yeah
she didn't believe it so she lied to me
told me that she called her and told me
that the girl had told her that me and
the girl seen each other all been
[ __ ] away ever just just to try and
catch me out to say like a half [ __ ]
sake it's not because of that or yeah
you caught me out like she I was like
what and she has no idea the
embarrassment she brought to me when I
came back to John Barris that was to
come back on campus because obviously
this girl's gonna tell everyone yeah
everyone James his crazy ass girlfriend
rang me me of all people because she
knew how little we knew each other yeah
she's thinking James Duncan's girlfriend
is [ __ ] off her rocker mmm I was so
embarrassed from I was so embarrassed
women are crazy not me that was a red
flag I decided to ignore it there's
another time I was walking into the
station train station and another girl
that mutual friend at the time walked
past and literally all I did was say hi
we're walking past her on the street
sure we were walking up straight she
looking down straight she looked some
issues of high house are high my
governor time decided to have a
screaming match with me in the middle of
the street like who the flying [ __ ] is
that and I was like some girl brough
just some girl from uni like I don't
know her I know Tom I didn't even know
her I just know it you just you just
know people to say hi to and then you
don't know them she was like I'm [ __ ]
sick of this every time I see he was
another girl was another this is another
that in the middle of the street near
the library where everyone was
congregating no fun fam no ignored that
as well you know obviously I did
obviously I did I had nothing I was
going there someone to do that to me now
oh I would love that
hola it'll be comedy bring a camera
because some someone is preparing me
where's Ashton Kutcher cuz you must be
pranking me because if you think if you
think for a second you can embarrass me
like that I'll leave you on the street
I'll leave you right street rights right
bro there's certain things you put up
with when you younger there you cannot
you can ever imagine
you can't put you could never do that to
me now never I'm so much wiser now Oh
much away right then I hadn't I had no
other [ __ ] to go to yeah I had nothing
else going for me and I was ugly ugly
then I'm ugly ugly now but I was ugly
then looking back at pictures now
I was hideous she's all I had she was
she was at the time looking like she was
at the time it's true sacrifice you
gotta sacrifice your own dignity to pull
up and such bro that's exactly what I
did
and then the day I broke up with her I
remember it got to such a predictable
peak that was chillin with my boy at
home on Facebook I remember telling you
yeah she was online and I had a friend
request from another mutual friend yeah
and I said to my boy all right I'm gonna
accept this friend request from disco if
she pops up in the next 10 minutes to
say anything about this girl I'm
breaking up with her because she's
monitoring my [ __ ] to the nth degree and
I just can't handle any more that she's
crazy and he was that cool cool call me
I didn't believe she was actually gonna
pop up and leave it it he broke clicked
except before my page had refreshed
popped up who the [ __ ] is that who the
[ __ ] is that now and I was like we're
done here I did she just out I said
we're done
names we're done it's been a good three
years of what we're done the sex was
good we had some good times man the last
one more lovely I wish you all the best
but it's not happening no I can't do
this anymore you're crazy crazy you're
crazy you're a little crazy person what
goes through women's heads it's not just
women obviously I'm sure guys are crazy
out there as well like I'm very
protective and whatnot but guys are
definitely it's it's just I can only or
we can only speak from the female
perspective because we're not the crazy
ones I don't have any crazy guys that's
the thing is most women are crazy I'm
just gonna say I go [ __ ] most women are
crazy but they're crazy to a certain
degree you can it's like kind of
predictable crazy they're crazy about
certain [ __ ] and it's predictable and
you can kind of laugh it off but hardly
any guys are crazy but when they are
they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ] doubt Zubin
say [ __ ] you can't even comprehend yeah
in a big manish sure what's it you say
you need to go to prison they'll cut
like they're crazy bro
[ __ ] crazy I'm glad none of them my
friends so they could be I don't know
undercover
anyway am I the [ __ ] right am I the
[ __ ]
right so today for amide [ __ ]
am I the [ __ ] for not oh okay
am I the [ __ ] for not wearing a bra
mm-hmm when I'm with my boyfriend so
she's I'm assuming she is she's 25 he's
26
that's why I sit here so let's give it
the backbone long story short I'm
basically flat-chested a cup peak there
you know what yeah you know what I have
had a couple egg cups that are
phenomenal we'll get back to it but I'm
I'm moving away from from some firm tits
eyes the only compromise for me is if
your titties are flat you have to have a
back oh yeah well if your tees are flat
you've got to be small like if your toe
if you're like five eight and you got
flat chest there's something wrong it's
red there's something wrong that's red
you have to be like five one five two
flat chest and a decent body then I'm
like I'm okay with that for me I don't
know what it is for me I used to be
about the tits makes you about the
tails's now anyway but I don't know the
more women I'm seeing in my life the
more I have a I have a weird sense of
appreciation for everything different
things every day and I've never like is
very rare now but I look at like someone
I think he's banging yeah and think if
she had biggity to be there like I don't
look I'll just like I have a different
yeah I appreciate different things and
small tits of science so we're your age
with pride fun um yeah long story short
I'm basically flat-chested a cup
my boyfriend and I argue a lot and one
of the things he constantly points out
is that I don't wear a bra sexy but are
uncomfortable for me because they're
always too big to read they always this
is actually peek all right let me try
and get four it is SP they're
uncomfortable with me because they're
always too big they look and feel stupid
on me and I just hate them
as Christ he commented in an argument
that I wore one when we first dated
brackets
I wore a push-up to look good in the
dresses I had Gang Gang
she was trying are this guy's an awesome
which I stopped wearing after he saw me
naked gang by then there's no point he'd
already seen why I look like fun
no no I lack a lot of confidence when it
comes to my body and every time I want
to go out he demands I wear a bra
nothing low-cut nothing tight he makes
comments about not wanting people to
stare at my nipples I wear baggy clothes
around him all the time and he still
complains what am I the [ __ ] for not
wearing a bra or not he's a psychopath
the psychopath we're talking about what
took my earlier rags big man he's a
[ __ ] Oh his way is she is she has
overcome her confidence by one I've seen
first day she wore push-up bra to entice
you mmm and you were gassed off that and
then now that you guys are together
she's bawling around no bra on because
one day she's confident with you because
she knows she's got a cups is nothing to
do about unless you gets her her titties
done which I'm sure she doesn't wanna do
because if you wanted to do that
she would've goddamn done so she's
confident with their a cups but because
of the fact that you don't want people
to stare at her nipples big man
of course her [ __ ] balls brother
pigman you see what you were getting
into it's the same thing as the chick
from the last episode you knew what you
were getting into so why complain two
years down the line marks
brav these times yeah these men are
[ __ ] I can't stand guys that like no
one has change people they want to
change people due to their own
insecurities yeah if your [ __ ] oh and
you're scared that next month who cares
like I literally don't give a [ __ ] about
like my girlfriend could be posting
thirst trap yeah I literally don't care
like it doesn't bother me I'm not that
insecure like especially if that's the
thing that enticed me to it in the first
place 100% especially if she's telling
me to my face like big man I don't like
wearing bras they're actually kind of
embarrassing for me because they're too
big they're uncomfortable for me like I
wanna go braless and the only reason I
was wearing one in the first place was
to impress you and now that you've seen
me naked I'm more comfortable around you
so I feel confident or not wear bras how
can she tell you that and then you still
say no nothing I said I don't want you
wearing nothing tight shut the [ __ ] up
you need to lock him off 40:25 you can
find someone else
20:05 ximenos he's always an [ __ ]
he's an ass off and make you feel like
that yeah - he doesn't care about your
feelings is there in the fact that like
you said he knew what he was getting
herself into he knew for a fact the bra
push up around the first day was to
entice you do you know I mean yeah
what's right you seen me naked
you sees me there's nothing else unless
I hole s I've said to myself I'm saying
as I'm the woman if I've said to myself
oh I want to get my tits done then maybe
you can have something to say yeah I'm
confident or happy or comfortable with
my a-cups so yeah you can tell them
stress the buy it my wife likes me date
today but I am alright with then I lived
of it I've got a man I'm comfortable and
confident I'm happy who are you to tell
me that I don't need to wear this let me
do that because I don't people to stare
at your nipples let them stare at let
them stare cuz that's what I got there's
literally one today I'm your girl when
you're my mind so short it shouldn't
matter what people say it doesn't matter
bro girls get stared at every sing will
you rub your girl gets there because you
had the fattest he's in a fatty sauce
how would you feel then bro tell me
you're acting crazy now he will stop
someone then I would like when people
will stare at my go anyway like I said
it just doesn't bother me like I'm just
just me if I would gas me I'm walking
down the road with my girl when I see a
guy peek at a nip something oh I'm like
cuz exactly what we said earlier when
you see a guy but if you said you saw a
black guy with a white girl yeah any
black thick planning white guy think
he's please [ __ ] him I don't think I
want to get his goal I don't think I
want to [ __ ]
I think he's lucky and he's happy these
two guys are having good okay I can only
imagine the sex they're putting down
porn sex like porn upset bro yep
throw in shape so if I'm walking down
the street and I'm seeing a girl with
the little teaser she's proud and the
I'm seeing the nipples
fruit I'm like she's one local son tie
these my kinky I know you appreciate the
small tease bro
your man is a waste now why is it your
money so what and also he's an awesome
yeah your man's an [ __ ] man shut up
he's a fob just cheap shoe on his ass
right there's another man that's gonna
[ __ ] appreciate another man's gonna
trust me and trust me but before we go
guys follow us on swear money as much as
we were funny on like live on like the
YouTube and the put the audio sorry we
tweet retweet daily bro interactive us
the bet is the best way obviously a lot
of people will interact with us via the
comments on YouTube and via the comments
obvious sorry we are Instagram DM but
Twitter is the quickest way because
obviously we get it straight away it's
just so much better because we can
actually up a conversation with Eugene I
mean it doesn't sound weird it's so just
follow us and shit's and gigs it's at
shits and gates but the is sh x CS and
gigs yeah follow us man have a
conversation we're always gonna respond
we always like to have a laugh hence the
shit's and gigs so you know just you
know shout shout and then follow us on
patreon as well obviously you do to sing
you know yeah man YouTube subscribe Oh
Jerry Potter Marvin run me my peas Tempe
a day you know section